PROFESSOR: So we've
been discussing
Szemeredi's regularity level
for the past couple of lectures.
And one of the
theorems that we proved
was Roth's theorem, which tells
us how large can a subset of 1
through N be if it has no
3-term arithmetic progressions.
And I mentioned at
the end of last time
that we can construct
fairly large subsets of 1
through N without 3-term
arithmetic progressions.
I want to begin today's lecture
with showing you that example,
showing you that construction.
But first, let's
try to do something
that is somewhat more naive,
somewhat more straightforward,
to try to just construct
greedily 3-AP-free sets of 1
through n.
And recall from last time,
we showed Roth's theorem
that such a set must
have size little o of N.
So what's one
thing you might do?
Well, you can try to greedily
construct such a set.
It will just make our
life a little bit easier
if we start with 0 instead of 1.
So you put one
element in, and you
keep putting in
the next integer,
as long as it doesn't create a
3-term arithmetic progression.
So you keep doing this.
Well, you can't put 2
in, so let's skip 2.
So we go to the next one, 3.
So 4 is OK.
So we skip 5.
We have to skip 6 as well
because 0, 3, 6, that's a 3-AP.
So we keep going.
So what's the next
number we can put in?
AUDIENCE: 9.
PROFESSOR: Up.
Go to 9.
Then the next one is 10.
What's the next
one we can put in?
So we can play this game.
Find out what is the next
number that you can put in.
Greedily, if you
could put it in,
put it in in a way that
generates a subset of integers
without 3-term
arithmetic progressions.
So this actually
has a name, so this
is called a Stanley sequence.
And there's an easier way
to see what the sequence is.
Namely, if you write
the sequence in base 3,
you find that these numbers
are 0; 0, 1; 1, 0; 1, 1.
1, 0, 0.
1, 0, 1.
1, 1, 0.
1, 1, 1.
So these are just numbers
whose base 3 representation
consists of zeros and ones.
So I'll leave it to
you as an exercise
to figure out why this is
the case, if you generate
the sequence greedily this way,
this is exactly the sequence
that you obtain.
But once you know that, it's
not too hard to find out
how many numbers you generate.
So up to-- suppose N
is equal to 3 to the k.
We get 2 to the k
terms, which gives you
N raised to the power
of log base 3 of 2.
So you can figure out what that
number is, but some numbers
strictly less than 1.
And actually, for
a very long time,
people thought this was
the best construction.
So this construction was
known even before Stanley,
so it was something that is
very natural to come up with.
And it was somewhat of a
surprise when in the '40s,
it was discovered
that you can create
much larger subsets of
the positive integers
without arithmetic progressions.
So that's the first thing
I want to show you today.
So these sets were first
discovered by Salem and Spencer
back in the '40s.
And a few years later, Behrend
gave a somewhat improved
and simplified version of the
Salem-Spencer construction.
So these were all
back in the '40s.
So these days, we
usually refer, at least
in the additive
combinatorics community,
to this construction as
Behrend's construction.
And this, indeed, what I will
show you is due to Behrend,
but somehow, this Salem-Spencer
name has been forgotten
and I just wanted
to point out that it
was Salem and Spencer who first
demonstrated that there exists
a subset of 1 through
N that is 3-AP-free
and has size N to the 1 minus
little o 1, that there's
no power saving.
So there exists examples
with no power saving.
And this is important
because as we
saw last time, the proof
of Roth's theorem--
and we basically spent
two full lectures
proving Roth's theorem.
And it's somewhat
involved, right.
It wasn't this one
line of inequality
you can just use to
deduce the result.
And that is part
of the difficulty.
So having such an
example is indication
that Roth's theorem
should not be so easy.
That's not a rigorous
demonstration,
but it's some indication of the
difficulty of Roth's theorem.
So let's see this
construction due to Behrend.
So let me write down
the precise statement.
There exists a constant, C, such
that there exists a subset of 1
through N that is 3-AP-free
and has size at least N times e
to the minus C root log N.
Perhaps somewhat amazingly
enough, this bound
is still the current best known.
We do not know any
constructions that
is essentially better than
Behrend's construction
from the '40s.
There were some small
recent improvements
that clarified what the C
could be, but in this form,
we do not know anything
better than what
was known back in the '40s.
And the construction,
I will show yow--
hopefully you should believe
that it's quite simple.
So I will show you what
the construction is.
It's clever, but
it's not complicated.
And it's a really interesting
direction to figure out
is this really the best
construction out there.
Can you do better?
So let's see.
We're going to set some
parameters to be decided later,
m and d.
Let me consider x to be this
discrete box in d dimensions.
So this is the box of lattice
points in d dimensions, 1
through m raised to d.
And let me consider
an intersection
of this box by a sphere
of radius root L.
So namely, we look
at points in this x,
such that the sum
of their squares
is equal to exactly L. You
take a bunch of these spheres,
they partition your set x,
so the smallest possible sum
of squares, largest
possible sum of squares.
So in particular, there
exists some L such that x of L
is large, just by
pigeonhole principle.
You can probably do this
step with a bit more finesse,
but it's not going to change
any of the asymptotics.
The intuition here-- and we'll
come back to this in a second--
is that xL lies on a sphere.
So this is the set
of lattice points
that lies in a given sphere.
And because you are looking at
a sphere, it has no 3-term APs.
So we're going to
use that property,
but right now it's not yet
a subset of the integers.
So what we're going to do is to
take this section of a sphere
and then project it
to one dimension,
so that it is now going to
be a subset of integers.
And we're going to
do this in such a way
that it does not affect
the presence of 3-term APs.
So let us map x to the
integers by base expansion.
So this is base 2m expansion.
All right.
So what's the point of this
construction here so far?
Well, you verified a couple
of properties, the first being
that this construction here
is injective, this map.
So if you call this map
phi, this phi is injective.
Well, it's base expansion,
so it's injective.
But also a somewhat
stronger claim
is that if you
have three points--
so if you have
three points in x,
that map to a 3-AP
in the integers,
then the three points
originally must be a 3-AP in x.
Again, this is not a hard claim.
Just think about it.
Here, because we're
using base 2m expansion
and you're only allowed
to use digits up to m,
you don't have any
wrap around effects.
You don't have any carryovers
when you do the addition.
So combining these
two observations,
we find that the image of
xL is a 3-AP-free set off 1
through N. So what is N?
I can take N to be, for
instance, 2m raised to power d,
so all the numbers up there
are less than this quantity.
And the size is
the size of x sub
L, which is N to the d
divided by d m squared.
And now you just need to
find the appropriate choices
of the parameters m and d to
maximize the size of x sub L.
And that's an exercise.
So, for instance, if you take
m to be e to the root log
N and d to be root
log N, then you
find that the size here is
the bound that we claim.
And that finishes the
construction of Behrend,
giving you a fairly
large subset of 1
through N without 3-term
arithmetic progressions.
And the idea here is you
look at a higher dimensional
object, namely, a higher
dimensional sphere which
has this property
of being 3-AP-free,
and then you project
it onto the integers.
Any questions so far?
OK.
So we have some proofs,
we have some examples.
So now let's go on to
variations of Roth's theorem.
And I want to show you
a higher dimensional
version of Roth's theorem.
So I mentioned in the
very first lecture--
so you have this whole host
of theorems and additive
combinatorics--
Roth, Szemeredi,
multi-dimensional Szemeredi.
So this is, in some sense,
the simplest example
of multi-dimensional
Szemeredi theorem.
And this example is
known as corners.
So what's a corner?
A corner is, well, we're
working inside two dimensions,
so a corner is simply three
points, such that the two--
so they're positioned like
that-- such that these two
segments, they are
parallel to the axes
and they are the same length.
So that's, by definition,
what a corner is.
And the question
is, if you give me
a subset of a grid
that is corner-free,
how large can this subset be?
Here's a theorem.
So if A is a subset of 1
through N with no corners,
particular, no three points
of the form, x comma y;
x plus d comma y;
and x comma y plus d,
where d is some positive
integer, then the size of A
has to be little o of N squared.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Do we only
care about corners
oriented in that direction?
PROFESSOR: OK, good question.
So that's one of
the first things
we will address in this proof.
So your question was, do we
only care about corners oriented
in the positive direction.
So you can have a more relaxed
version of this problem
where you allow d to
be negative as well.
The first step in
the proof is we'll
see that that constraint
doesn't actually matter.
Yes.
OK.
Great.
Let's get started.
So as Michael mentioned, we do
have this constraint in this
over here that d is positive.
And it's somewhat annoying
because if you remember
in our proof of Roth's theorem,
they are positive, negative,
they don't play a role.
So let's try to find a way
to get rid of this constraint
so that we are in a
more flexible situation.
So first step is
that we'll get rid
of this d being
positive requirement.
So here's a trick.
Let's consider the sumset
A plus A. So sumset
here means I'm looking at
all pairwise sums as a set.
So you don't keep
track of duplicates,
so you'll keep it as a set.
And we're living
inside this grid,
but now somewhat wider in width.
Then there exists an element
in this domain of the sumset.
By pigeonhole,
that's represented
in many different ways.
So there exists a z
represented as a plus b
in at least size of
A squared divided
by size of 2N squared
different ways,
just because if you look
at how many things come up
in that representation,
just use pigeonhole.
And now let's take A prime to
be A intersect z minus A. So
what's happening here?
So you have this set
A. And basically what
I want to do is look at the--
so suppose A looks like that.
So look at minus A
and then shift minus A
over so that they intersect in
as many elements as you can.
And by pigeonhole,
I can guarantee
that their intersection
is fairly large.
So because the size
of A prime, it's
essentially the number of
ways that z can be represented
in the aforementioned manner.
So it suffices to show that A
prime is little o of N squared.
If you show that,
then you automatically
show A is little o of N squared.
But now A prime is symmetric.
A prime is symmetric
around 0 over 2.
So this is centrally
symmetric about z over 2,
meaning that A prime
equals to z minus A prime.
And so you see now
we've gotten rid
of this d positive requirement
because if A prime had
a positive corner, then it has a
negative corner and vice versa.
So no corner in A
prime with d positive
implies that no corner
with d negative.
So now let's forget
about A and A prime
and just replace A
by A prime and forget
about this d positive condition.
So let's forget about this part,
but I do want d not equal to 0.
Otherwise, you have trivial
corners, and, of course,
you always have trivial corners.
All right.
So let's remember how the
proof of Roth's theorem went.
And this relates to the
very first lecture where
I showed you this connection
between additive combinatorics
on one hand and graph
theory on the other hand,
or you take some
arithmetic pattern
and you try to
encode it in a graph
so that the patterns
in your arithmetic
set correspond to
patterns in the graph.
So we're going to do
the same thing here.
So we're going to encode
the subset of the grid
as a tripartite
graph in such a way
that the corners correspond
to triangles in the graph.
So I'll show you how to do this
and it will be fairly simple.
And in general, sometimes it
takes a little bit of ingenuity
to figure out what is the
right way to set up the graph.
So one of an upcoming
homework problem
will be for you
to figure out how
to set up a corresponding
graph when the pattern is not
a corner, but a square.
If I add one extra point up
there, how would you do that?
So what does this
graph look like?
Let's build a
tripartite graph where--
so this should be
somewhat reminiscent
of the proof of Roth's theorem--
where I give you three sets,
x, y, and z; and x and y
are both going to
have N elements
and z is now going
to have 2N elements.
x is supposed to
enumerate or index
all the vertical
lines in your grid.
So you have this grid of
N by N. So x has size 4.
Each vertex in x corresponds
to a vertical line.
y corresponds to the horizontal
lines and z corresponds
to these negatively
sloped diagonal lines--
slope minus 1 lines.
And of course you
should only take lines
that affect your N by N grid.
So that's why there
are this many of them
for each direction.
So what's the graph?
I join two vertices if
their corresponding lines
meet in a point of
A. So I might have--
this may be A, a
point of A. So I
put an edge between
those two lines--
one for x, one for z--
because their intersection lies
in A. And more explicitly--
I mean, that is
pretty explicit--
and alternatively,
you could also
write this graph by
telling us how to put
in the edge between x and z.
Namely, you do this if x
comma z minus x lies in A;
you put an edge between x
and y if x comma y lies in A;
and likewise, you
put in the final edge
if z minus y comma y lies in A.
So two equivalent descriptions
of the same graph.
Any questions?
All right.
So the rest of the proof
is more or less the same
as the proof of Roth's
theorem we saw last time.
So we need to figure out
how many edges are there.
Well, every element of
A gives you three edges.
So that's one of the edges
corresponding to that element.
The other two pairs
with two other edges.
And most importantly, the
triangles in this graph,
I claim, correspond to corners.
So what is a triangle?
A triangle corresponds
to a horizontal line,
a vertical line, and
a slope 1 minus line
that pairwise intersect
in elements of A.
If you look at their
intersections, that's a corner.
And conversely, if you have a
corner, you build a triangle.
And because your graph, your
set is corner-free, well,
you don't have any triangles.
Actually, no, that's not true.
So like we saw in
Roth's theorem,
you have some triangles,
but corresponding
to trivial corners.
So triangles correspond
to trivial corners
because your set
A is corner-free.
Trivial corners, meaning the
same point with d close to 0,
so it's not a genuine
corner like that.
And in particular,
in this graph,
every edge is in
a unique triangle.
And so we're in
the same situation.
By the corollary of
triangle removal lemma,
we find that the
number of edges must
be little o of the
number of vertices.
The number of edges
must be subquadratic,
so it must be little
o of N squared.
And so that implies
that the size of A
is little o of N squared.
So that proves the
Corners theorem.
Any questions?
So once you set up
this graph, the rest
is the same as Roth's theorem.
So this connection between
graph theory and additive
combinatorics, well,
you need to figure out
how to set up this graph.
And then sometimes it's
clear, but sometimes you
have to really think hard
about how to do this.
All right.
What does corner have to
do with Roth's theorem,
other than that they have
very similar looking proofs?
Well, actually, you can
deduce Roth's theorem
from the Corners theorem.
And to show you this precisely,
so let me use r sub 3 of N
to denote the size of the
largest 3-AP-free set of 1
through N.
So this notation, the r sub 3
is actually fairly standard.
The next one's not so standard,
but let's just do that.
So that's not an L,
but that's a corner.
So that is the size of the
largest corner-free subset
of N squared.
So we gave bounds
for both quantities,
but they are actually related to
each other through this fairly
simple proposition
that if you have
an upper bound for
corners, then you
have an upper bound
for Roth's theorem.
Indeed, given A a 3-AP-free
subset of 1 through N,
let me build for you
a corner-free subset
of the grid that is a fairly
large subset of that grid.
I can form B by setting
it to be the set of pairs
inside this grid whose
difference, x minus y,
lies in A. So what
does this look like?
This is the grid of size 2N.
And if I start with A that
is 3-AP-free, what I can do--
so over here--
is look at the lines like that,
putting all of those points.
And you see that
this set of points
should not have any corners
because if they have corners,
then the corners would
project down to a 3-AP.
So B is corner-free.
To recap, if we have
upper bound on corners,
we have upper bound
on Roth's theorem.
But you also know
that if you have lower
bound on Roth's
theorem, then you
have lower bound on corners.
So the Behrend construction we
saw at the beginning of today
extends to, you know, through
exactly this way to a fairly
large corner-free subset.
And that's more or less the best
thing that we know how to do.
In fact, there aren't
that many constructions
in additive combinatorics
that's known.
Almost everything
that I know how
to construct that's
fairly large come
from Behrend's construction
or some variant
of Behrend's construction.
So it looks pretty simple.
It comes from the '40s,
yet we don't really
have too many new ideas
besides playing and massaging
Behrend's construction.
Let me tell you what is
the best known upper bound
on the Corners theorem.
This is due to Shkredov.
So the proof using
triangle removal lemma,
it goes to Szemeredi's
regularity lemma.
It gives you pretty
horrible bounds,
but using Fourier
analytic methods--
so you see if you have
upper bound on Roth,
it doesn't give you an
upper bound on corner,
so you need to do
something extra.
And so the best known bound
so far is of the form,
N squared divided
by polylog log N,
so log log N raised to
some small constant,
C. Any questions?
Last time, we discussed
the triangle counting lemma
and the triangle removal lemma.
Well, it shouldn't
be a surprise to you
that if we can do
it for triangles,
we may be able to do
it for other subgraphs.
So that's the next thing
I want to discuss--
how to generalize the
techniques and results
that we obtain for
triangles to other graphs,
and what are some
of the implications
if you combine it with
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
So let's generalize the
triangle counting lemma.
So the strategy for the
triangle counting lemma,
let me remind you, was that
we embedded the vertices one
by one.
Putting a vertex and
a typical vertex here
should have many neighbors
to both vertex sets.
So these two guys should
have sizes typically roughly
the same as a fraction
of them corresponding
to the edge density
between the vertex parts.
And if they're not
too small, then
from the epsilon regularity
of these two sets,
you can deduce the number
of edges between them.
So that was the strategy for
the triangle counting lemma.
So you can try to extend the
same strategy for other graphs.
So let me show you how
this would have been done,
but I don't want to give
too many details because it
does get somewhat hairy
if you try to execute it.
So the first strategy is to
embed the vertices of H one
at a time.
So my H now is going
to be, let's say, a K4.
And I wish to embed
this H in this setting
where you have these four parts
in the regularity partition,
and they are pairwise epsilon
regular with edge densities
that are not too small.
Well, what you can try to
do, mimicking the strategy
over there, is to first
find a typical image
for the top vertex.
And a typical image
over here, minus
some small bad exceptions,
will have many neighbors
to each of the three parts.
Next, I need to figure out
where this vertex can go.
I'm going to embed this
vertex somewhere here.
Again, a typical
place for this vertex,
modulo some small fraction,
which I'm going to throw away.
So now you see you need
somewhat stronger hypotheses
on the epsilon regularity,
but they are still
all polynomial
dependent, so you just
have to choose your
parameters correctly.
So this typical green
vertex should have
lots of neighbors over here.
So you just keep embedding.
So it's almost this
greedy strategy.
You keep embedding
each vertex, but you
have to guarantee that there
are still lots of options left.
So embed vertices one at a time.
And I want to embed each vertex
so that the yet to be embedded
vertices have many choices left.
So epsilon regularity guarantees
that you can always do this.
And you do this all
the way until the end
and you arrive at
some statement.
And depending on
how you do this,
the exact formulation
of the statement
will be somewhat
different, but let
me give you one statement
which we will not prove,
but you can deduce
using this strategy.
And this is known as a
graph embedding lemma.
And again, as I
mentioned when I started
discussing
Szemeredi's regularity
lemma, the exact statements,
they are fairly robust
and they are not as important
as the spirit of the ideas.
So if you have some
application in mind,
you might have to go into
the proof, tweak a thing
here and there, but
you get what you want.
So the graph embedding
lemma says, for example,
that if H is bipartite, and with
maximum degree and most delta--
so the H maximum
degrees at most delta--
and suppose you have vertex
sets V1 through Vr, such
that each vertex set
is not too small;
and if these vertex sets
are pairwise epsilon
regular and the density
is not too small.
So here I'm assuming
some lower bound
on the density which
depends on your epsilon.
Then the conclusion is that
G contains a copy of H.
I just want to give a few
remarks on the statement
of this theorem.
Again, we will not
discuss the proof.
So what is this
hypothesis on H being
r-partite have to
do with anything?
So here, as an example,
when r equals to 4, instead
of this K4, maybe I also care
about that graph over there.
Well, maybe some more
vertices, some more edges,
but if it's 4-partite.
And the point is that I want
to embed the vertices in such
a way that that top
vertex goes to the part
that it's supposed to go into.
So I'm embedding
this configuration
in the same way that corresponds
to the proper coloring of H.
So if you do this,
there's enough room still
to go, as long as you have
some lower bound on the edge
density between the
individual parts,
and you only depend really
on not the number of edges
of H, but the maximum degree.
Because if you look at how
many times each vertex,
its possibilities can be shrunk,
it's in most delta times.
Now, this graph
embedding lemma--
so I give you this
statement here,
but it's a fairly
robust statement.
And if you want to get, for
example, not just a single copy
of H, if you want to
get many copies of H,
you can tweak the
hypotheses, you
can tweak the proofs
somewhat to get you
what you want, again, following
what we did for the triangle
counting lemma.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is the bound on the H
edge density between partitions
correct?
So if the maximum
degree increases,
the lower bound decreases?
PROFESSOR: If maximum degree
increases, this number goes up.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: I want to
show you a different way
to do counting that does not go
through this embedding vertices
one by one, but
instead we will try
to analyze what happens if
you take out an edge of H one
by one.
And that's an alternative
approach which I like more.
It's somewhat less
intuitive if you are not
used to thinking about
it, but the execution
works out to be much cleaner.
And it's also in line with
some of the techniques
that we'll see later on when
we discuss graph limits.
Let's take a quick break.
Any questions so far?
We will see a second strategy
for proving a graph counting
lemma.
And the second strategy is
more analytic in nature,
which is to embed, well, to
analytically somehow we'll
analyze what happens when
we pick out one edge of H
at a time.
So let me give you
the statement first.
So the graph counting
lemma says that if you
have a graph H with vertex
set elements of 1 through k--
I also have an epsilon
parameter and I
have a graph G and subsets
V1 through Vk of G,
such that Vi Vj
is epsilon regular
whenever ij is an edge of H.
So here, the setup is slightly
different from the picture
I drew up there.
So what's going on
here is that you have,
let's say, H being this graph.
And suppose you are
in a situation where
I know that some of these--
so I know that five of these
pairs are epsilon regular,
and what I really want
to do is embed this H
into this configuration.
So 1, 2; V1, V2; and so on.
And I want to know how many
ways can you embed this way.
The conclusion is
that the number
of tuples, the number of such
embeddings, such that Vi, Vj
is an edge of G for all
ij being the edge of H--
so exactly as
showing that picture,
the number of such
embeddings, the little v's, is
within a small error, which
is the number of edges
of H epsilon times the total,
the product of these vertex
set sizes of this number,
which is what you would predict
the number of embeddings to be
if all of your bipartite graphs
were actually random.
So like in the triangle
counting lemma,
if you look at the edge
densities in this configuration
and predict how many
copies of H you would get,
that's the number you
should write down.
And this counting
lemma tells you
that the truth is not so
far from the prediction.
Any questions?
So we will prove
the graph counting
lemma in an analytic manner.
It helps to-- so it
will be convenient
for me to rephrase the
result just a little bit
in this probabilistic form.
So it has the equivalent
to show that if you
have uniformly randomly chosen
vertices, little v1 and big V1,
and so on--
so little vk and big VK.
So they're independent,
uniformly, and random,
then the probability--
so basically, I am putting
down a potential image
for each vertex of
H and asking what's
the probability
that you actually
have an embedding of H.
So the probability that
little vi, little vj
is an actual edge of G for
all ij being an edge of H,
this number here, we're
saying that it differs
from the prediction, which is
simply multiplying all the edge
densities together.
So the difference between the
actual and the predicted values
is fairly small.
So I haven't done anything,
just rephrasing the problem.
Instead of counting, now we're
looking at probabilities.
As I mentioned, we'll take
out one edge at a time.
So relabeling if
necessary, let's assume
that 1, 2 is an
edge of H. So now we
will show the following
plane, so I'll denote star.
That, if you look at
this quantity over here
compared to if you take out
just the edge density between V1
and V2, but now you put
in a similar quantity
where I'm considering all of
the edges of H, except for 1, 2.
I claim that this difference
is, at most, epsilon.
So you can think
of this quantity
here as the same quantity as
the green one, except not on H,
but on H minus the edge 1, 2.
To show this star claim, let us
couple the two random processes
choosing these little vi's.
By that, I mean here you have
the random little vi's and here
you have the random little vi's,
but use the same little vi's
in both probabilities.
So in both, there are two
different random events,
but you use the
same little vi's,
it suffices to show this
inequality star with--
so what's this process,
this random process?
You pick V1, you pick V2,
you pick V3, all of them
independently
uniformly at random.
But if I show you the inequality
under a further constraint
of arbitrary V3 through VN,
then that's even better.
So with V3 through
Vk, fixed arbitrary,
and only little v1
and little v2 random.
So you can phrase this in terms
of conditional probabilities,
if you like.
You're comparing these
two probabilities.
Now I fix the V3's
through Vk's, and I just
let V1 and V2 be random.
And if condition on V3 through
Vk, you have this inequality,
then letting V3
through Vk go, letting
them be random as well,
by triangle inequality,
you obtain the bound
that we're looking for.
Any questions about this step?
If you're confused about
what's happening here,
another way to bypass all
the probability language
is to go back to the
counting language.
So in other words, we're
trying to count embeddings.
And I'm asking if you
arbitrarily fix V3 through Vk,
how many different choices
are there to V1 and V2
in the two different settings.
OK.
So let A1 be the set of
places where little v1 can go,
if you already knew what
V3 through Vk should be.
OK.
So you look at all the neighbors
of V1, neighbors of 1 and H,
except for 2.
And I want to make
sure that V1, Vi, as i
ranges over all such neighbors,
is indeed a valid H in G.
I'll draw a picture in a second.
And A2, likewise, is
the same quantity,
but with 2 instead of 1.
So for example, if you're
trying to embed a K4, what's
happening here is that you have
this V1, this V2, and somebody
already arbitrarily
fixed the locations
where V3 and V4 are embedded.
And you're asking, well, how
many different choices are now
left for little v1.
It's the common
neighborhood of V3 and V4.
So that's for A1.
And V3 and V4, also their
common neighborhood in B2 is A2.
OK.
So with that notation,
what is it that we're
trying to show over here?
So if you rewrite this
inequality with the V3's
through Vk's fixed, you find
that what we're trying to show
is the following.
So we claim-- and this
claim implies the star,
that if you look at what
the first term should be--
so this is the number of
edges between A1 and A2
as a fraction of the
product of V1 and V2.
And then the second
guy here is if you use
the prediction d of V1 and V2.
So this is each of them,
each of these two factors,
there's a probability
that little v1 lies in A1,
little v2 lies in
A2, and then you
tack on this extra constant,
namely, this constant here.
So we're trying to show that
this difference is small.
And the claim is that this
difference is, indeed,
always small.
There's always, at most, epsilon
for every A1 in V1 and A2
in V2.
And here, in particular,
so this statement
looks somewhat like the
definition of epsilon
regularity, but
there's no restrictions
on the sizes of A1 and A2,
and they don't have to be big.
And as you can imagine,
this statement,
we're not really
using all that much.
All we're assuming is
the epsilon regularity
between B1 and B2.
So we will deduce
this inequality
from the hypotheses of epsilon
regularity between B1 and B2.
So let's check.
So we know that B1 and B2 is
epsilon regular by hypotheses.
So if either A1 or
A2 is too small,
so if A1 is too small
or A2 is too small,
then we see that
both of these terms
here are, at most, epsilon.
So if the A's are too small,
then neither of these terms
can be too large.
Here it's bounded by--
if you took the
product of A1 and
A2 and likewise over there.
So in this case, their
difference is, at most,
epsilon, and we're good to go.
Otherwise, if A1 and A2 are both
at least an epsilon fraction
of their [INAUDIBLE]
sets, then we find that--
so what happens?
So here, so by the hypothesis
of epsilon regularity,
we find that d of
V1 and V2 differs
from the number of
edges between A1 and A2,
divided by the product
of their sizes.
So that's just d of A1 and A2.
So this difference is, at most,
epsilon, which then implies
the inequality up there.
So here we're using
that the size of A
is, at most, the size of V.
So we have this claim.
And that claim proves
this inequality in star.
And basically,
what we've done is
we showed that if you
took out a single edge,
you change the desired quantity
by, at most, an epsilon,
essentially.
So now you do this for every
edge of H. Alternatively,
you can do induction on
the number of edges of H.
So to complete a
proof of the counting
lemma, so we do induction
on the number of edges of H.
And when H has exactly one
edge, well, that's pretty easy.
But now if you have
more edges, well, you
apply induction
hypothesis to the graph,
which is H minus the edge 1, 2.
And you find that
this quantity here
differs from the
predicted quantity
by the number of edges of
H minus 1 times epsilon.
In other words, you run
this prove that we just
did one edge at a time.
So each time you
take out an edge,
you use epsilon
regularity to show
that the effect of taking
that edge out from H
does not have too big of an
effect on the actual number
of embeddings.
Do this for one edge at a
time, and eventually you
prove the graph counting lemma.
So this is one of
those proofs which
may be less intuitive compared
to the one I showed earlier,
in the sense that there's not
as nice of a story you can tell
about putting in one
vertex at a time.
But on the other hand, if you
were to carry out this proof
to bound each time how
big the sets have to be,
it gets much hairier over here.
And here, the execution is
much cleaner, but maybe less
intuitive, unless
you're willing to be
comfortable with
these calculations.
And it's really not so bad.
And the strength of these two
results are somewhat different.
So again, it's not so much the
exact statements that matter,
but the spirit of
these statements, which
is that if you have a bunch
of epsilon regular pairs,
then you can embed and kind
of pretending that everything
behaved roughly like random.
Any questions?
So now we have Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma,
we have the graph counting
lemma, embedding lemmas,
we can use it to derive some
additional applications that
don't just involve triangles.
So when we only had a
triangle counting lemma,
we can only do the
triangle removal lemma,
but now we can do
other removal lemmas.
So in particular, there's
the graph removal lemma,
which generalizes the
triangle removal lemma.
So in the graph removal
lemma, the statement
is that for every H
and epsilon, there
exists a delta, such
that every N vertex
graph with fewer than
delta N to the vertex
of H number of copies of H--
so it has very few copies of H--
such graph can be made
H-free by removing
a fairly small number of edges.
All right, so same statement
as the triangle removal lemma,
except now for general graph H.
And as you expect, the proof
is more or less the same
as that of a triangle
removal lemma,
once we have the
H counting lemma.
So let me remind
you how this goes.
So it's really the same
proof as triangle removal,
where there was this recipe
for applying the regularity
lemma from last time.
So what is it?
You first-- so what's the first
step when you do regularity?
You partition.
So let's do partition.
OK.
So apply the regularity
lemma to do partitioning.
And what's the second step?
So we clean this graph.
And you do the same
cleaning procedure
as in the triangle
removal lemma,
except maybe you have to adjust
the parameters somewhat, so
remove edges, remove
low density pairs,
irregular pairs, and
small vertex sets.
And the last step--
OK, so what do we do now?
OK.
So you can count.
So if there were any H left,
then the counting lemma
shows you that you must have
lots of copies of H left.
So now let me show you
how to use the strategy.
Now that we have this
general graph counting lemma,
we'll prove the
Erdos-Stone-Simonovits theorem,
which we omitted,
the proof that we
omitted from the first
part of the course.
So remind you, the
Erdos-Stone-Simonovits theorem
says that if you have a graph
H, then the extremal number of H
is equal to this quantity
which depends only
on the chromatic number of H.
The lower bound comes from
taking the Turan graph.
If you take the Turan graph,
you get this lower bound,
so it's really the upper bound
that we need to think about.
All right.
So what's the strategy here?
The statement really
is that if you
have a graph G that's N
vertex whose number of edges
is at least that much--
OK, so I fixed an
epsilon bigger than zero,
fixed a positive epsilon.
So the claim, what we're
trying to show with
Erdos-Stone-Simonovits, is that
if you have a graph G with too
many edges-- too many
meaning this many edges--
then G contains a copy of H
if N is sufficiently large.
OK.
So let's use the
regularity method,
so applying this
three-step recipe.
First, we partition.
So partition the vertex
set of G into m pieces,
and in such a way that
it is eta regular--
and for some parameter eta
that we'll decide later.
The second step is cleaning.
The cleaning step,
again, it's the same kind
of cleaning as
we've done before.
So let's remove an
edge from Vi cross Vj,
if any of the following hold--
if Vi Vj is not A to
regular, if the density is
too small, or either the
two sets is too small.
So same cleaning as before.
And we can check that the
number of edges removed
is not too small.
So in the first
case, so again, it's
the same calculation
as last time.
In the first case, the
number of edges removed
is, at most, eta N squared.
And we'll choose eta to be
less than epsilon over 8,
although it will be actually
significantly smaller,
as you will see in a second.
In the second step, same as
what happened in the triangle
removal stage, the
number of edges
removed in the second type
is, at most, that amount,
still very small number.
And the third one here is
also a very small number.
So the third type, they
start with one of these sets,
the m possible--
so it's a very small number.
And so the total is, at most,
an epsilon over 2 N squared.
So maybe I want epsilon over--
so let's say epsilon over 2
N squared number of edges.
And I would like that to
be strictly bigger than.
So now after removing
these edges from G,
we have this G prime, which has
strictly more than 1 minus 1
over r.
Yeah, 1 minus 1 over r times
N squared over 2 edges.
So now what do we do?
So we knew from Turan's theorem
that if your graph has strictly
more than this number of edges,
you must have a K sub r plus 1.
So even after deleting
all these edges,
G still has lots of edges
left, in particular,
Turan's theorem implies
that G prime contains
a clique on r plus 1 vertices.
So here I should say that r is
chromatic number of H minus 1.
So I find one copy
of this clique,
but what does that
copy look like?
I find this one
copy of a clique.
Let's say r equals to 4.
And the point, now, is that
the counting lemma will allow
me to amplify that
clique into H.
So it will allow me to amplify
this clique into a copy of H.
So, for example, if H
were this graph over here,
so then you would find a copy of
H in G, which is what we want.
So why does the
counting lemma allow
you to do this amplification?
So it's this point, the
ideas are all there,
but there's a slight
wrinkle in the calculations.
I mean, there's,
in the executions,
I just want to point
out, just in case
some of the vertices of H end
up in the same vertex in G.
But that turns out
not to be an issue.
So by counting lemma, the
number of homomorphisms
from H to G prime, where
I'm really only considering
homomorphisms that
map each vertex of H
to its assigned part.
It's at least this
quantity where
I'm looking at the predicted
density of such homomorphisms,
and all of these edge densities
are at least epsilon over 8.
So it's at least that amount
minus a small error that
comes from the counting lemma.
And, well, all of
the vertex parts
are quite large, so
all of the vertex parts
are of size like that.
So that's the result of
the counting lemma combined
with information about
the densities of the parts
and the sizes of the parts
that came out of cleaning.
So setting eta to be
an appropriate value,
we see that for
sufficiently large N,
this quantity here,
is on the order of N
to the number of vertices
of H. But I'm only
counting homomorphisms,
and so it
could be that some
of the vertices of H
end up in the same vertex
of G. And those would not
be genuine subgraphs,
so I shouldn't
consider those as subgraphs.
Because otherwise, if
you were to allow those,
then if you found
this K4, then you
found all four chromatic graphs.
So you shouldn't consider
copies that are degenerate,
but that's OK because the number
of maps from the vertex set
of H to the vertex set of
G that are non-injective
is of a lower order.
The number of non-injective
maps from the vertex set,
well, you have to
pick two vertices of H
to map to the same vertex, and
then the number of choices,
you have one order less.
So there are negligible
fraction of these homomorphisms.
And the conclusion,
then, is that G prime
contains a copy of H, which
is what we're looking for.
If G prime contains copy of H,
then G contains a copy of H,
and that proves the
Erdos-Stone-Simonovits theorem.
You get a bit more
out of this proof.
So you see that not only
does G contain one copy of H,
but the counting lemma
actually shows you
it contains many copies of H.
And this is a phenomenon known
as supersaturation, which
you already saw in
the first problem set,
that often when you are
beyond a certain threshold,
an extremal threshold, you
don't just gain one extra copy,
but you often gain many copies.
And you see this
in this proof here.
So to summarize,
we've seen this proof
of Erdos-Stone-Simonovits,
which comes
from applying regularity
and then finding
a single copy of a clique
from Turan's theorem,
and then using
counting lemma to boost
that copy from Turan's theorem
into an actual copy of H.
So in the second homework,
one of the problems
is to come up with a different
proof of Erdos-Stone-Simonovits
that is more similar to the
proof of Kovari-Sos-Turan,
more through double-counting
like arguments.
And that is closer in
spirit, although not
exactly the same as the
original proof in Erdos-Stone.
So this regularity proof, I
think it's more conceptual.
You get to see how
to do this boosting,
but it gets a terrible bound.
And the other proof that
you see in the homework
gives you a much
more reasonable bound
on the dependence
between how N grows
versus how quickly this
little o has to go to zero.